sociopathy sure so the more common term
is a sociopath so sociopathy is the
condition of being a sociopath
sociopaths are individuals that have
very low capacity for empathy they do
not display normal love they do not
appear to experience remorse they may
experience regret you know person if you
back your car into something you will
feel regret whether you're a sociopath
or not because you have to deal with the
aftermath but you know if you run over
somebody's pet if you're normal you will
feel terrible at the pain you've caused
and if you're a sociopath you may feel
very little beyond annoyance do you
think that that's a disorder no I think
it makes very little sense to think of
it as a disorder and I'll tell you why I
mean the first thing is the commonality
of it so it seems to be that somewhere
between 1 and 4 percent of the
population is sociopathic that's a very
high a high number for a disorder and it
could be that you have something like
you know lead in the water could cause 1
to 4 percent of the population to be you
know mentally [ __ ] in some
recognizable
way but you wouldn't find it broadly
distributed across an entire culture in
this way
it's also true that we see sociopaths in
many regards rising to the top of of
economic hierarchies and political
hierarchies so it's conspicuous that's
something that we have wanted to label
as a disorder seems to be like a
superpower for a certain number of
people so disorder is probably not the
right category I also think we draw two
starkly the line between sociopaths and
the rest of us I think essentially all
of us are sociopathic in some regards
with respect to some things and probably
we have to be this way so we will all
recognize that we can hear about the
suffering of a population that is remote
from us either in space or in time and
we can feel very little even if in the
abstract what is happening to that
population is frightening or abhorrent
to us we may be able to hear about it
and then gone about our day you know go
buy a coffee or whatever where we could
you know we could have had our lives
pivot around the discovery that there
were people suffering and yet it only
captures our attention momentarily so
that strikes me as the experience of
being sociopathic largely because the
population that we're talking about is
too far for us to do anything productive
and so it wouldn't make sense for us to
feel the emotion deeply because it would
be disruptive of things that we actually
do have influence over I think it is
also really important to grapple with
the the lesson I would say of something
like an organized-crime leader an
organized-crime leader if the narratives
we have about these folks is right may
very well love their family passionately
and they may go very far out of their
way to provide benefits and to protect
their families from harm and at the same
time they may be able to turn off their
feelings of sympathy or empathy with
people that they have to harm in order
to engage in the criminal activity that
they engage in and so when we see
somebody who is in a position of control
and an organized crime Network give an
order that does harm to innocent people
we think this must be a sociopath but
that doesn't square with the definition
of sociopaths and with somebody who goes
home to to their family and as a
sevillio a relationship with them I
think this is a much richer landscape
than we give it credit for and we should
think very carefully about the fact that
people have a sociopathic capacity in
order to function normally so it's not
to be overwhelmed by the huge amount of
suffering in the world and so is not to
be too focused on events or
circumstances too far or too powerful to
do anything about and that when we when
we refer to sociopaths we're really
talking about people who are obligate
who have no choice and no capacity to
tap into the suffering of others when
need be and that that is a special case
but there's no reason to think that just
because it's at the far end of a
continuum of you know how how tapped
into other people's emotional states an
individual is that it is suddenly a
disorder once you get to the end of the
continuum I would imagine in ancestral
circumstances that there are cases in
which effectively one might be of value
to one's lineage in a form that was that
couldn't be disrupted by by observing
suffering soldiers on a battlefield for
example might be very effective if they
could tune out the immense amount of
suffering around them and do their job
in a more or less mechanical fashion so
I do wonder if the truth of sociopaths
is that in ancestral circumstances they
would have been pointed outward so that
their sociopathic tendencies would have
been a benefit to their lineage because
of what they could do to competing
groups and that what we are seeing the
reason we think of this as a disorder is
that people's sociopathic powers are
turned chaotically and some of them are
turned you know in close quarters
against people who are part of the
in-group and there
or are not supposed to be the target of
this of this pattern but that it really
is an adaptation just deployed in a way
that doesn't make any sense you're using
these words sympathy and empathy what do
you mean by well in this case I've used
them somewhat interchangeably because it
requires some careful thought to see why
there they should be defined in the way
they should be defined but in a formal
sense sympathy is empathy with an extra
characteristic empathy is in my language
it is the capacity to feel the emotions
of another by taking the data of their
circumstances and running it through
one's own mental architecture as if you
were their sympathy you do the same
thing with the acknowledgement that you
are effectively on the same team as the
entity the person or the creature with
whom you are sympathizing so the example
that I think makes this clear is we
empathize with people to know what
they're going to do because that
provides advantages evolutionarily
that's true whether the person that
you're empathizing with is your your
ally or your enemy so it's very
important for example to be able to
empathize with Hitler in the bunker as
the Allies approach right you can
understand exactly why he puts a gun to
his head and shoots himself because he
knows what's coming
but you shouldn't sympathize with them
he was a monster and he deserves no
sympathy whatsoever so the empathy is is
a tool it's a means to an end to
discover what another individual is
likely to do so that you can position
yourself relative to that behavior
sympathy is empathizing with somebody
with whom you have allegiance and
therefore you know
one feels the pain of somebody on their
team when that person has experienced a
misfortune personally one feels some
fraction of that pain themselves and so
sympathy is the same pathos you feel the
same way whereas you know in the case of
your enemy if you're empathizing with
them
you may feel exactly the opposite with
respect to what's happened they may
experience in misfortune and you may
feel joy at the fact that they screwed
up so you don't feel the same emotion
you understand you feel the emotion that
they feel you correctly predict it but
your reaction to it may be very
different
a sociopath who does very well may be
very good at predicting the behavior and
feelings of others without feeling them
themselves so they would lack sympathy
but they may be capable of empathizing I
think this is a place that we actually
get sociopathy wrong we imagine that
they are incapable of empathy because
there are certain places where they are
a bit tone-deaf there are certain
experiences in being a human being that
are not usually described very well and
so a sociopath may have a hard time
picking up what it really would be like
to have that emotional experience
so things surrounding love and grief and
things like that may be a bit hard for
them to put their fingers on but in
general they may be very attuned to what
somebody's psychological state is
because somebody else's psychological
state may constitute an opportunity or a
hazard to them and being aware of it is
is useful even just mechanically so
their empathy only extends to the point
where usefulness and
well actually I would say it a little
differently I would say the empathy that
I see sociopaths being best at is
learning the lessons of emotional states
that are visible and to the extent that
an emotional state is difficult to see
into I mean think of how confusing
profound grief is profound grief is just
the most remarkably complex state where
you know at one moment you're you know
completely lost in despair and then 10
minutes later you're doing something
productive and you you're not thinking
about the loss and so that oscillation
has to be bewildering if you've never
experienced because it seems like you
know being productive it puts the lie to
the fact that you were debilitated only
moments ago and you know only if you've
experienced that and you know how real
it is to oscillate between being focused
on this terrible loss and being in
another mindset doing something else and
not thinking about it only if you've
done that do you realize that that
transition is even possible
let alone the common experience of grief
so you know when a sociopath sees this
not having felt the despair at the loss
of somebody that they loved I think they
think we're playing or something or that
maybe that's the evidence that we're not
really as despairing as we appear to be
in that phase or something so anyway it
can be can be very revealing when you
get to those few places in life where
it's rare to see a really good
description of the experience those are
places that a sociopath would have a
very difficult time simulating the
experience because nothing has described
what it's really like
I suspect we can do a brilliant job with
sociopathy but that we can't deploy the
solution on a population that's already
gone through development and
to be very effective with it that what
we would need to do is understand what
the frame of mind of somebody is as they
switch between their sociopathic and
their empathic mode and then train that
switch so that it is tuned to the
realities of of life and I would say
with respect to the obligate sociopath
that ideally a civilization that
functions should provide no profit to an
individual for externalizing harm onto
other people and if you actually took
that seriously such that there was no
opportunity to get ahead by hurting
people then a sociopath would not find
opportunities of the rest of us find
troubling they would be corralled into
behaviors that were at least not harmful
and so they might be harder to recognize
because their motivations for doing
something might be different from what
another person might be motivated by but
the behavior that resulted might be very
similar because there would be no profit
in harming people and walking away
without feeling bad about building
systems that don't reward that behavior
ought to be a focus at every at every
scale the price that we pay at every
scale for people's betrayals of each
other is very very high and frankly if
you want civilization to function well
you want it to produce
the stuff of well-being at the highest
rate possible so that everybody has the
experience of living in an abundant
world and that takes a good bit of
engineering to make that a stable State
so that people don't capture more than
their share of the well-being and turn
it into machinery of power I think we
should use developmental environments to
increase the degree to which we
sympathize with each other in other
words I think we have inherited from our
ancestors a capacity for sympathy that
is too narrow and that it is very
important that we be able for example to
sympathize with generations yet unborn
because we unlike our ancestors have the
power to destroy their environment so in
some sense we need to be able to feel
the harm that we do to people
10-12 generations down the road in order
to protect them adequately from us our
tools are such that we can wreak
civilization in a single generation and
so the degree to which this needs to be
emphasized is greater than any ancestral
group will likely have intuited but but
that's where we are and so in some sense
we have to alter the developmental
landscape not only to be healthy but to
be modified for the new realities that
being a modern
being as has handed us people who have
no capacity to tap into the emotions of
others are obviously a special hazard
and we need to watch out for it but you
know I think the story of human
variation is a rich and sometimes a
difficult story and that the desire to
you know to do away with dyslexic or you
know people who have other kinds of
neurological diversity is a mistake and
so anyway I would be I'd be hesitant to
say that we should do anything extreme
with respect to people on a continuum
but we do want to rule out the behaviors
in which people get ahead by producing
harm for others at the same time
learning what developmental experiences
cause a person to become compassionate
probably something we should know and as
soon as we know what makes people
compassionate I would love to see it
induced in more people at a greater
level
there we go I need to kill them that
wasn't a sound test no that was a
mosquito test and it passed
unfortunately oh yes no their chronic
impasse and they're just trying to tap
into your inner essence
yeah the fields are incredible